so adam22 has the show called no jumper
so as you guys know I've been going back
and forth on Twitter with adam22. he'll
call me single and childless I'll say
you pimped out your wife you know what
you know what it is so anyway so
what Adam 22 does is he he has
interviewed many porn stars rappers
entertainers on his show and overall
like I would say it's very high
production his team's very professional
and even even I was on there okay and
so but what I what I wanted to point out
was adam22 called me a misogynist okay
remember that remember that I Pearl am a
misogynist okay yet this is some of the
consequences of coming on his platform
so let's play play the clip on my
birthday I was getting in a hotel room
they all put up and I sucked there the
whole team seven seven basketball
players in a row how was that swallowed
all of them yeah do you look back at
this as a positive memory yeah I don't
care is this a few moments later I'm not
proud of that story anymore I'm in you
know reformed oh you reformed now
balance she reformed three years ago
she's not proud of that story but I'm
also not ashamed and like people can't
come in my DMs and like make me feel
horrible when I was 21 I've been living
my best life that was three years ago
when she was 21. moved on and I've
learned from that and I honestly think
it's a funny story and you still think
money you feel some type of way about it
no matter how you try to sugarcoat it
because if you didn't feel a certain
type of way about it you would have made
this video okay so
now mind you this isn't Adam's fault
this is that chick's fault okay that's
that's the consequences of her own
actions but you know following his life
path why do you think she regrets it now
why do you think she regrets telling
that story now
oh because there's consequences because
the stuff he pushes leads women to be
single and childless
I mean the stuff he put not not only
that the stuff he pushes really leads
women to destruction you think she's
going to get married have kids you think
what's her future now it's really either
porn or only fans so who is the real
misogynist the one that's telling you
the truth and being honest with you
about the consequences or the one that's
pushing a lifestyle where you suck off
seven dudes in one night like this is
this is crazy guys and this is the
problem with the left you know they guys
themselves as non-judgmental loving Etc
but who who really cares about you the
the people that are telling you what you
want to hear the people telling you the
truth and and that's the bot and that's
the bottom line of the matter is that we
need to Value honesty Above All Else we
need we need to be honest and the truth
of the matter is doing that is is you're
done there there's no light at the end
of the tunnel no one's really going to
take you seriously after that and you
know it's her own fault for doing it but
the lifestyle he promotes and honestly
he assists women in doing this guy
assists women in joining the porn
industry he manages them and look at I
mean it's legal but
I mean who's the real misogynist
the one helping assisting women and
making decisions that will ruin their
prospects of having a marriage and a
family
um or the one
that's telling them the truth
and you know you could call me what you
want but at least I'm honest at least
I'm honest so
you know and this is this is kind of the
trend that the guys have seen where at
21 the chicks are doing this wild crazy
stuff and then at 25 all of a sudden
they're reformed and ladies you know God
can forgive you but men don't have to
and I want you to really hear this you
know God can't forgive you God will
forgive you but men don't have to and
the truth of the matter is your actions
are a direct reflection of the husband
you get so if if you choose to do this
it's probably going to be none at all
and and the more you do the the less
likely it is you're really going to end
up with anyone and that's the truth of
the matter so be careful what you do
don't put a bunch of like that on
the internet and guys I mean I don't I
never thought I'd have to be in a world
well where I'd have to say don't suck
seven guys off in one night
I mean what
I mean that's don't have sex on camera
you know and this is why you need strong
masculine fathers women should know
they'll be disowned they would
villainize their dads for not accepting
them being gay not accepting them doing
ho not accepting them leaving the
church that's what they're supposed to
do that's what fathers are meant to do
you guys want masculine men but then you
shame them for doing the very thing that
makes them masculine protection they're
supposed to protect you but we live in a
world where the media and the messaging
is telling women to go down this crazy
crazy route and this is the thing I'm so
tired of these men simping and just
telling us what we want to hear ladies
like we need to be done being pandered
to I'm so done with it I don't want to
be pandered to anymore